il est encore temps
sophie dont il parle à l'imparfait car
je les trouve mon fils c'est un enfant
de fiançailles alors pour le faire
grandir les médecins contre bordés au
monde à prendre quelques années plus
tard il y as il succombé à la maladie de
crohn maladie incurable qui entraîne une
dégénérescence du serbe
en fait les hormones de croissance
étaient contaminés aujourd'hui l'état
propose d'indemniser toutes les familles
concernées par ce drame
mon avis et qu on les embête un peu mais
je crois que ils haïssent au tremplin
s'ils veulent le faire ça pour nous
faire taire non je crois pas c'est moi
personnellement je ne dirais pas autant
que je n'ai pas cherché un responsable
les responsables de ce drame
parce qu'ils veulent comprendre les
bernois n'ont déposé une plainte pour
homicide involontaire et même qu'ils
acceptent l'indemnisation ne retombe en
plein à l'époque au moins deux parents
d'enfants ont reçu comme leur fille
cette hormone de croissance
une vingtaine de clubs de contamination
sont officiellement recensés dans cette
affaire un rapport de l'inspection
générale des affaires sociales parle de
négligence et de maladresses de la part
des responsables
le gouvernement a donc décidé de ne pas
tergiverser
chaque famille recevra 2 millions de
francs 5 en dommages et intérêts retour
hier il faut dire que c'est une
catastrophe puisque cette maladie
conduite à une mort certaine et que
cette l'état décidé de prendre à sa
charge sur le budget du ministère de la
santé une les indemnités qui seront
versées discuter contractuellement
directement avec les familles pour
apprécier le pour apprécier complètement
le le dommage
un pont dubuc et en formant la foire